[Music]
and Lord knows millions of people are
obsessed with all the Real Housewives
the ladies of Atlanta will sit down for
their reunion special Sunday night and
tomorrow the New York caskets a new
member and here's the thing she comes
with the rap sheet
ten years ago Tinsley Mortimer was the
most photographed woman in New York City
Dior even named a lipstick after her
Tinsley pink but last year this mugshot
became her most talked-about photo ever
she was arrested for trespassing on her
ex-boyfriends property in Florida I went
back to his house to get a bag back of
mine and we got in a big fight there and
he I couldn't get the bag back so I
called the police to help me get the bag
back that's when I found out that they
could arrest me for being on the
property which was a complete shock to
me
me coming back to New York and and me
even doing the show and stuff it's like
all about me like you know taking my
power back
with a back story like that Mortimer
fits right into her new gig as the
newest addition to the Real Housewives
of New York look for the 41 year old
socialite to butt heads with Bethenny
Frankel and side was Sonja Morgan who
she's been living with since moving back
to the Big Apple what was Sonja like as
a host I had roles you know one it was
not to take the elevator
wait the elevator was off limits
I can't bring a guy home okay fair
enough well I didn't know that at first
I just didn't know that that was a rule
so I found out some
like I did come over and on my back
trouble and we
[Music]
you